c'est jean-jacques l'intermédiation nom
que s'est il passé dimanche pendant la
parade carnavalesque du nord ce que l'on
sait c'est qu'il y a eu des frictions
juste en face de la gendarmerie entre
deux côtés des carnavaliers arborant des
drapeaux rouge vert noir et de l'autre
des gendarmes
en revanche deux versions s'opposent
quant aux raisons de l'altercation
l'un des carnavaliers présent livre sa
version avant que la colle à la peau
comme ça à ce moment là et le jeune
homme les hôtes de la lap le drapeau des
diorios et la poule 2 derrière nous
comme on est un peu dispersé patron
d'apple a fait à ce moment là lui il a
comme jeune homme a fait sa peau c'est
en tentant de récupérer le drapeau qui
leur appartenaient que le groupe aurait
reçu du gaz lacrymogène
du côté des gendarmes pas de
communication officielle mais
l'institution conteste tout lien avec le
drapeau
les militaires auraient répondu à des
provocations sans pour l'instant
préciser lesquelles une enquête
judiciaire est en cours
quoi qu'il en soit militants associatifs
politiques ou simples citoyens
martiniquais ans aujourd'hui apporter
leur soutien à teddy le des carnavaliers
impliqué convoqué pour ivresse sur la
voie publique
outrage et rébellion vous dites que le
drapeau est attaqué très concrètement
qu'est ce qui illustre cette attaque le
fait que un gendarme ci où le drapeau et
qu'il le récupéra si il y avait un
trouble à l'ordre public
ils se seraient tournés vers l'individu
causa le trouble mais là on tient un
drapeau
donc c'est le drapeau qui attaquait
évidemment quand les jeunes veulent de
retenir le récupérer ils sont agressés à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes c'est
absolument intolérable etc nous ne
devons pas accepter sans que martinique
est digne en ce moment il peut les nier
qu arrêter là
2e concours qui sont lancées pour
retrouver le rapport alors qu'on a des
ingrats pour historique
donc c'est vraiment pas le manquer à sa
part le moment de toucher à notre
drapeau ne touchez pas à nos droits dans
le fait-il qu'en aval de manifester
d'aller à la mer de se retrouver qui
voudra surtout personne ne le touche le
drapeau était-il viser les carnavaliers
ont ils provoqué les forces de l'ordre
ou y at il une réponse excessive des
gendarmes
une enquête a été ouverte et confiée au
parquet après un peu plus d'une heure
d'entretien
teddy est reparti libre de la
gendarmerie du lorrain
[Musique]